ok ok ok
[Musique]
hop là ça s'est fait un peu tendance à
la vidéo maintenant attendait notamment
les youtuber son démonétisé des tas de
vidéos et apparemment les youtuber font
aussi ce métier uniquement pour l'argent
et ça voudrait dire que en assemblant
ces deux informations on obtiendrait des
youtube europe allan mes amis
aujourd'hui on va parler des changements
qu'a eu sur youtube ces derniers temps
il ya pas mal de choses à dire je vais
aborder ça en trois grands arcs comme un
animé japonais style et sauf qu'ici il
n'est ni question d'animer ni question
d'un truc style et la d re fois j'avais
fait ce genre de vidéo c'était il ya un
bon moment déjà où j'avais parlé de la
mode de dire aux gens à tout prix des
mais la vidéo est mais la vidéo
maintenant ma fille c'était il ya déjà
un moment maintenant cesser complètement
calme et tout simplement parce que ça ne
sert à rien les gens ont compris que ça
ne référence est pas mieux les vidéos on
va donc commencer par parler de
l'algorithme le fantasme de tous les
créateurs celui dont on veut percer les
secrets celui qui peut rendre quelqu'un
riche et connu ou à leurs pauvres et
dans l'indifférence totale
j'ai pas mes trucs à dire dessus parce
que youtube ne donne toujours aucune
info pour la simple et bonne raison que
sinon les gens réussirez à le comprendre
et à faire ce qu'il faut pour que la
vidéo soit mise en avant même si elle ne
le mérite pas du tout mais de ce que
j'ai remarqué je trouve que ça va
vraiment mieux en tout cas la longue les
des tendances est vraiment bien géré par
rapport à avenches tout et je dis ça
alors que moi je me retrouve mille fois
moins tendance que par exemple il ya un
an mais c'est mérité dans le sens où
actuellement l'algorithme se base sur
combien de vue fait ta vidéo en moyenne
dans les 24 premières heures ou dans les
12 premières heures ou dans les six
premières heures et ce qui est bien avec
ça c'est que ça ça laisse la place à des
nouvelles personnes c'est pas toujours
les mêmes qui sont en tendance et on
découvre maintenant je trouve beaucoup
plus qu'avant des nouveaux créateurs pas
forcément nouveau mais en tout cas des
créateurs dont on n'avait pas forcément
entendu parler et c'est hyper bien pour
eux c'est eux qui ont besoin de cette
visibilité c'est eux qui ont besoin de
ce coup de pouce et c'est un système qui
est génial voilà je voulais vous en
parler parce que on a très souvent chier
sur l'onglet des tendances sur comment
ça marche et c'est parce que les youtube
heurts dont au moins on a de lego qu'on
n'est pas mise en avant par le grand
maître youtube on le vit mal on se sort
rejeté je mérite ma place en attendant
ce qui est voulu youtube pourront
décider à ma place c'est vraiment servi
maintenant c'est fou et bien aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression que ça fonctionne
comme je viens de vous le dire alors
attention c'est ce que je pense un
youtube n'a rien communiqué là-dessus
mais je vois de plus en plus de vidéos
qui avant n'était jamais en tendance et
qui pourtant sont très cools ya par
exemple ya pas longtemps la copine de
déruns qui a lancé sa chaîne youtube et
de hutus n'y en a parlé dans une de ses
vidéos du cool après la vidéo de sa
copine a fait beaucoup beaucoup de vue
pour une nouvelle chaîne youtube et hop
elle a tapé le top intendance et c'est
mérité c'est très bien voilà c'est mon
avis sur ça en tout cas je suis très
contente ça c'est trop cool ça permet
aux jeunes créateurs d'être vraiment
bien
avant et gagner beaucoup en visibilité
c'est eux qu'on en a besoin je le
rappelle donc c'est magnifique
voilà la deuxième chose la raison pour
laquelle les youtuber ne font plus leur
courses aux galeries lafayette
maintenant ils font leurs courses à
leader price n'est ce pas écoeurant ne
méritent ils pas mieux ces grands
youtuber ces dieux la démonétisation
alors universal music vous connaissez
très bien le plus gros labels du monde
je pense comme l'un des plus grands en
tout cas et monétise à l'appel détail
des tas et des tas de vidéos je crois
que terra sida la médaille d'or de la
démonétisation vraiment il s'est fait
[ __ ] un nombre colossal de vidéos vous
savez tous comment ça marche voilà on
utilise un extrait peu importe sa durée
d'une musique qui est soumis à des
droits d'auteur donc qui est
généralement et publié par universal et
distribué par universal du coup quand le
robot youtube détecte pas utiliser cette
musique là ils te dis oh là là tu n'as
pas droit je te démonétise ou alors
quand le robot détectent pas le truc
c'est directement quelqu'un de chez
universal qui tourne sur ta vidéo et qui
revendique la monétisation j'ai moi même
eu des tas et des tas et des tas de
vidéos démonétisé bad façon peut-être
vidéos mises en ligne depuis toutes ces
années plus tard chance d'avoir une
démonétisation parce qu'à l'époque on
s'en bat les couilles d'utiliser des
musiques soumises à des droits d'auteur
alors qu'on savait très bien qu'on
n'avait pas le droit et c'est ça qui est
hypocrite je trouve la part des youtuber
youtube ou network ne nous ont jamais
dit allez-y utiliser ces musiques qui
sont soumises à des droits d'auteur y'a
pas tout si il ne vous arrivera jamais
rien pas du tout on savait tous très
bien que c'est interdit mais on savait
aussi qu'il pouvait pas contrôler toutes
les vidéos de tout le monde et que le
robot des fois quand tu mettais la
musique un peu plus aiguë ou un peu en
accéléré il passé à côté mais ce n'est
pas parce que le robot de youtube passe
à côté que tu as le droit pour autant et
donc on l'a on s'est pris un retour de
flamme dans la gueule comme ça qui nous
a brûlé le visage et qui à moitié mérité
quand même parce qu'on a joué avec le
feu alors pour des vidéos comme par
exemple joueur du grenier où ils base je
sais pas tout sa vidéo sur par exemple
harry potter et qu'il utilise des
musiques d'harry potter pour plonger les
spectateurs dans l'ambiance d'harry
potter c'est dégueulasse il mériterait
d'avoir une autorisation et d'avoir le
droit d'utiliser ça c'est un peu sa
marque de fabrique quand il fait des
vidéos à thème comme ça mais pour des
gens comme moi des petits chenapans où
on veut juste faire une blague qu'on
veut est illustré par une musique jean
loup titanic pendant 4 secondes et on
n'en démord pas on veut pas utiliser une
on veut celle du titanic
alors on peut l'utiliser techniquement
mais notre vidéo sera juste pas
monétiser mais comme on veut aller faire
nos courses aux galeries lafayette on
veut est la musique et la monétisation
donc on triche et cette petite technique
a marché pendant bien longtemps jusqu'à
ya quelques mois quand universal se sont
dit
bien combien à gagner lors plusieurs
dizaines de millions ils ont mis leurs
meilleurs ingénieurs leurs meilleurs
éléments sur le coup et ils ont
construit selon moi c'est pas youtube
qui le dit mais selon moi un logiciel
qui détecte une mouche qui a été sur un
cadavre toutes les vidéos qui font des
vues dans lesquelles il ya des musiques
qui leur appartient c'est sûr vu la
quantité de vidéos dont il revendique la
monétisation que c'est un logiciel qui
détecte tout ça parce qu'il est glacé
que le logiciel ensuite averti quelqu'un
de chez universal qui vient comme ça
avec sa petite souris et qui fait au
plat au plat donc là pour bien
comprendre que la revendication de la
monétisation n'est pas automatique comme
le fait le robot youtube mais les
manuels c'est ça qui pose problème parce
que quand le robot youtube detec dans
l'une de tes vidéos une musique soumises
à des droits d'auteur il détecte sur
quel timecode elles et ils te propose de
muter l'extrait audio en question pour
récupérer ta monétisation et hop comme
ça tu peux aller aux galeries lafayette
mais quand c'est une revendication
manuel donc fait par quelqu'un de chez
universal ou un mode la belle la
personne n'a pas à dire deux camps à
quand la musique a été utilisé dans la
vidéo est donc toi tu n'as pas l'option
de muter uniquement le passage où la
musique passe afin de récupérer la
monétisation donc tu te fais
complètement [ __ ] est le souci de ça
c'est que universal fait d'être avec
manuel en masse mais avec la force de
frappe d'un robot à mon avis je pense
qu'ils sont tellement malin qu'ils
arrivent même à classer dans leurs
logiciels les vidéos par ordre de celles
qu'on fait le plus de vues dans les 24
ou 48 dernières heures et donc celles
qui vont leur apporter le plus de thunes
il ya aussi le fameux point morale du
bon bah tu fais une vidéo de 20 minutes
mais cinq secondes d'une musique soumise
à un droit d'auteur et c'est l'entièreté
de ta monétisation qui dégage et qui ava
au label alors que ça devrait être
calculée différemment ça devrait basé
sur le pourcentage de ta vidéo sur
lequel il ya la musique ou un truc du
genre voilà les youtuber rage un peu
parce qu'on s'attend un truc un peu plus
juste étant donné que les gens n'ont pas
à cliquer sur ta vidéo parce que dedans
y avait par exemple du david guetta ils
ont cliqué sur ta vidéo parce que tu as
fait une nature plus ta clique un titre
de connard et et la musique qu'il ya
dedans en rien ça t'a fait faire plus de
vue donc pourquoi tout l'argent que ça
génère irait au label bon voila mais
d'un autre côté comme j'ai dit on nous a
jamais dit qu'on pouvait utiliser toutes
ces musiques ce musée à des droits
d'auteur sans aucune répercussion jamais
on nous a dit ça donc je pense qu'il
faut un peu que l'on se remette en
question aussi et qu'on arrête d'être
têtu faudrait que l'on crée donc propre
musique et qu'on les fasse tourner entre
nous et qu'elle sait en créer nos
propres musiques de même deux alors oui
c'est dommage on peut pas utiliser des
musiques de film dans nos vidéos peut
parfois même utiliser des musiques de
même parce que bach en musique de drake
devient même bas ça reste une musique de
drake donc la royale label derrière mais
c'est la vie il faut faire un choix
techniquement on peut les utiliser mais
notre vidéo ne générera pas d'argent
donc c'est un choix mais bonne nouvelle
les
youtube a bien conscience de ce problème
là de l'abus de droit total des labels
etc
et du coup ils vont mettre en place une
mise à jour ou en fait la personne qui
serait créé un manuel mandat vidéo devra
dire le fameux time code sur lequel se
trouve
l'extrait de la musique est soumis à des
droits d'auteur et du coup le créateur
derrière pourra tout simplement cliquer
sur le fameux bouton pour muter
d'extrusion en question et ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle parce qu universal là on
va pas ce mytho ils ont abusé mon garde
donc merci youtube d'avoir écouté ce
problème et merci de mettre en place le
truc là prochainement je sais pas quand
mais je sais que ça va arriver
la troisième chose que youtube a fait et
là j'ai vu des gens il ya eu un groupe
chiffres au co à propos de ça et donc du
coup je veux rétablir la vérité désolé
ça va faire chez certains youtube ont
récemment mis en place un programme de
lutte contre les réseaux de
pédopornographie faut savoir qu'il ya
des vrais réseaux qui existent la
pédopornographie ça existe que c'est
punit très sévèrement par la loire sur
youtube il ya pas mal de vidéos qui
présentent des mineurs des chaînes comme
par exemple en france on a un studio
bungie et nos soins de vol et engrossé
des vidéos ou des enfants vont par
exemple ouvrir des jouets vont faire des
activités etc et les parents film tout
ça est fondée sur des blogs avec leurs
enfants voilà et c'est un truc qui plaît
aux enfants et c'est aussi un truc qui
plaît aux pédophiles et donc un nom en
dix ans seulement elle a sauté la
monétisation y avait plus de gens
d'universal et donc dans certains
espaces commentaires de vidéos du genre
on peut retrouver des commentaires
complètement horrible abject des
commentaires qui relève bien sûr delà de
la pédopornographie et surtout c'est des
vidéos qui sont partagés dans des
endroits du darknet des endroits obscurs
des forums très obscur et c'est là on
prend conscience que ça existait card
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
consomment ce genre de trucs et qui sont
adeptes à ça donc c'est très très grave
est horrible et donc youtube bien
évidemment sont totalement contre ça
comme chaque être humain sensé et du
coup ils ont mis une mesure en place ils
ont dit bon voilà nous les gars toutes
les vidéos présentant des mineurs on va
supprimer l'espace commentaire alors
tous les espaces commentaires des vidéos
contenant des mineurs ne contenait pas
des commentaires pédopornographiques
mais youtube a dû ratisser très très
très large pour être sûrs que ceux qui
ont contenu et bien été dégagés et
youtube a aussi du coude et monétiser
les vidéos susceptibles d'engendrer des
commentaires pédopornographiques dans
l'espace commentaire mais ils ont pas du
tout démonétisé toutes les vidéos qui
contiennent des mineurs et ça ça me fait
chier beaucoup et je vous avoue je
comprends pas tant pourquoi en fait il
ya une sorte de haine générale envers
ses chaînes là parce que les gens
trouvent que c'est les parents
exploitent leurs enfants déjà le mot
exploiter il est très fort c'est un mot
qui est très puissant mais comment
voulez prouver que les parents de ces
chaînes exploitent leurs
on n'en sait rien on sait pas c'est très
compliqué le deuxième argument que je
comprends un peu mais pareil il faut
prendre du recul par rapport à ça c'est
ouais mais regardez quand l'enfant va
grandir il a toute son enfance comme ça
en public sur youtube les gens vont se
moquer lieu à l'école etc
mais on n'en sait rien on n'en sait rien
du tout c'est les premiers à vivre ça
dont il n'y a pas eu d'exemples dans le
passé de ça on sait pas du tout si néo
par exemple quand il est arrivé au
collège de gens vont se moquer de lui ou
pas on n'en sait rien et surtout les
gens on a 26 on est pour savoir mieux
qu'une mère de 40 ans comment s'occuper
de ses enfants et comment gérer ça on
est personnes regardez moi je dois
m'occuper d'un chien je lui dis au bout
de ma vie je sais pas du tout ce que
c'est car dans un enfant humain donc je
trouve que c'est un peu hypocrite et je
vois là dedans surtout un bon gros
sommes une bonne grosse jalousie général
et je trouve que autant dans certains
cas j'avoue ça a l'air d'être un peu
chelou la relation entre les parents et
l'enfant on voit très bien dans
certaines vidéos que l'enfant est
vraiment pas très à l'aise il n'aime pas
du tout ce moment qu'il est en train de
vivre on sent même des fois qu'il a
envie de faire autre chose qu il est un
peu forcé etc
pour certaines vidéos donc ça c'est un
sujet très compliqué et voilà comme josé
dia thiam est de 10 personnes devant des
vidéos d'une de ses chaînes youtube là
il y en a cinq qui vont dire non aux
exploits de leurs enfants et 5 qui vont
trouver qu'ils exploitent leurs enfants
et que c'est pas bien pour les enfants
mais voilà c'est des valeurs morales ça
va dépendre de chacun d'entre nous on
n'a pas tous le même avis là dessus mais
en tout cas sur ses chaînes là je suis
désolé les enfants ont pas l'air en
souffrance ils ont pas l'air d'être en
détresse psychologique ou en détresse
physique qui sont franchement moi je
vais vous dire j'aurais adoré étant plus
jeune pouvoir aider mes parents déjà et
gagner leur vie en faisant des vidéos
avec eux et surtout vivre des trucs de
ouf comme ça ils venaient jouer souvent
ils vont tout le temps dans des bêtes
d'endroits à faire des bêtes de choses
en famille c'est trop bien et vivent des
truc génial géniaux pardon je sais plus
par les uns vraiment voilà dans certains
cas je suis d'accord avec les gens qui
détestent ces jeunes là mais dans
d'autres cas il faut juste qu'on arrête
d'avoir le sommes comme ça en fait y'a
pas de raison et surtout ceux sommes là
cette haine là qu'on peut avoir
vis-à-vis de ses chaînes l'arc en lamé
en public c'est nous en fait qu'ils ont
du mal aux enfants de ces chaînes là
c'est pas les parents c'est pas la
situation du tout c'est pas le fait
qu'ils fassent des vidéos c'est le fait
que des gens comme nous ait derrière
dans leur commentaire way sur les
réseaux les bâches et les démolir c'est
ça qui leur fait du mal je vous jure
bien plus que leurs parents avec la
situation qui est en train de vivre
voilà je vais juste mais qui sont bien
là dessus parce que je vois une n en
croit l envers ses chaînes là et ça veut
pas dire que toutes les chaînes il ya
des mineurs sont clean et tout se passe
bien les parents sont bienveillants et
tout est parfait pas du tout mais à
l'inversé veut pas dire que toutes les
chaînes comme ça c'est de l'exploitation
d'enfants etc des parents qui sont mal
intentionnées qui font pas attention à
leurs enfants qui font pas ce qu'il faut
pour qu'ils aillent bien et c'est enfin
voilà tout n'est pas tout blanc ou tout
noir il ya d entre eux deux attention
faut nuancer tout ça et voilà
ce que je voulais faire je voulais un
peu une immense et tous ces trucs là
parce que je vois vraiment un somme
totale envers ses chaînes là et parfois
c'est vraiment injustifié
c'est la fin de ce petit point sur les
nouveautés youtube live du coup c'est
pas les temps forts sur youtube de
février c'est les temps forts de youtube
tous ces trucs là qu'ont été mises en
place et très cool j'espère que youtube
va continuer dans cette voie là je
trouve qu avant il n'était pas du tout
transparent et maintenant ils gagnent en
transparence il ce matin même à faire
des sortes de communiqués où ils disent
ce qui à nouveau sur la plate forme etc
oui disent les actions qu'ils ont menées
au cours des mois passés que c'était un
contre quoi ils ont lutté qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont mis en place pour pour
détruire le truc et que ça s'est
vraiment bien donc voilà youtube
continuer comme ça et puis pour les
youtuber qui veulent plus être
démonétisé je vous invite à utiliser des
musiques libres de droits voilà il ya
plein de sites qui font ça il ya audio
jungle mais bon c'est 20 dollars la
musique mon groupe préféré seuil
épidémique sans doute parce que tu peux
triés par nout par genre par bpm fin par
plein de choses et du coup qui trouvent
beaucoup plus facilement la musique qui
était parfaite pour la situation de ta
vidéo qui avait choisi et surtout ça
fonctionne par abonnement est en fait
plus ta d'abonnés plus tu paies cher à
youtube heures qui a plus d'argent mais
il va payer plus et youtube heures qui a
moins d'argent à payer - et ça c'est
très cool voilà donc je vous le
conseille je mets mon petit lien de
parrainage si vous avez envie de m'aider
voilà tout simplement sinon bah je vais
essayer sur le site sans passer par mon
lien de parrainage et puis voilà il vous
en faites pas pour tout cela qu'on mg
dans pas longtemps l'aller prochaine
vague de revendications on pourrait
muter l'extrait audio en question et
récupérer la monétisation et ce sera
bien en la caméra s'est arrêté ça c'est
comme quoi youtuber démonétisé c'est ce
qui lui arrive et disparaît comme ça
pendant une heure dans la tristesse et
la chaîne un kebab annonce quittent sur
un écran noir tombé plus de batterie
c'est dommage parce que là je faisais
l'un des meilleurs tu que j'ai jamais
fait sur la chaîne honnêtement c'est
seulement vous pouviez voir c'est
vraiment
[Musique]